j'accueille maintenant
l'ex président de l' agence de
mannequins élite europe gérald marie
accompagnée de laurianne chabanol et de
leur racisme eros
bonsoir qui est l'organe
donc vous êtes laura je suis le rat
voilà bonsoir
bonjour elle marion vous invitez puisque
l'émission s'appelle tout le monde en
parle et s'il ya bien un truc dont tout
le monde parle en ce moment c'est votre
affaire donc je vais vous citer les
faits et vous donner l'occasion de
répondre vous êtes un peu gêné gens
j'essaye de ne pas faire trop tard
et je comprends
mettez vous sur les genoux de annonce à
cet accord à condition qu'on a c'est
vrai en voilà en temps normal notre ami
se serait assis sur les genoux de
maintenant que jean d'ormesson mais
compte tenu de ce qui se passe
effectivement marché ici c'est apprendre
michel noir son but
donc jérôme mary la france entière parle
de vous donc le mardi à cause d'un
reportage qui était diffusée sur la bbc
le mardi 23 novembre
un reportage de donal macintyre donc sur
les dessous de la mode quand amy grand
ami de notre grand ami oui qui a enquêté
pendant un an et en se faisant passer
auprès de vous pour un photographe de un
photographe de mode
on vous en croire qu'ils étaient frères
de mode alors qu'en fait ils
travaillaient pour un magazine en
famille le 10 et qui travaille pour un
magazine de presse un magazine américain
est en fait il avait une caméra cachée
et puis des magnétophones scotché comme
ça sur le corps
une méthode de
d'investigation qui est autorisé en
angleterre mais interdite en france il
faut bien le dire donc d'ailleurs la
cassette en france n'ont pas été
diffusés en france
pas jusqu'à aujourd'hui je pense pas qu
elle parce que c'est quelque part ça
aurait pu m'aider moi quel point cette
petite cassette sa mort éviter un peu le
vomi médiatique que j'ai pu subir et que
mon a fait à kiewit a subi plein dans
une semaine alors donc la cassette moi
je les ai vus je vais dire ce qu'il ya
dans cette cassette ce que j'ai vu puis
vous ma couperet vous marrez très si
vous pensez que c'est pas exact comme ça
nous ferons une émission équitable alors
on voit un relations publiques de boîte
de nuit qui n'a rien à voir avec vous
d'ailleurs qui rabat des modèles vers
les boîtes de nuit qui est payé ça
arrivera en france y en a aussi qui est
payé pour rabattre des top models sur
les boîtes de nuit qui dealent un peu
d'ailleurs voilà on voit une bookeuse
une boucle c'est la fille qui prend les
rendez-vous de lagence marilyn qui vend
de la drogue à la cocaïne à un mannequin
on voit un ex-mannequin s'appelle
christine bost est requis et qui était
d'ailleurs une ex à vous qui avait 14
ans quand vous l'avez découverte
qui dit derrière vous le faisiez bosser
jusqu'à l'épuisement et qui avait
toujours de la drogue à disposition
non mais voilà jusque là et qui dit que
vous êtes un petit peu le parrain de ce
milieu
donc quand les on est dans le phare
alors au sujet des lites maintenant
l'agent ce dont vous êtes le genre de
mannequins qui je crois la plus grande
du monde maintenant non absolument et
dont vous êtes le président fin dont
vous étiez parce que j'ai démissionné
les emplois qu'on voit xavier moreau
alors xavier moreau lui les responsables
du concours élite de luca venir et en
parlant du concours il dit que c'est un
stade plein de chatte
il dit aussi je sais pas je dis ce que
j'ai vu il dit aussi qu'il aime pas les
mannequins de couleur voilà il ya le
représentant du bureau de new york du
recrutement au bureau de new york qui
s'appelle olivier daube qui dit c'est
formidable
il dit c'est formidable de les aider
fille de 16 ans
voilà c'est formidable de baisers des
filles de saison
il ya chapron nous dit chapron d'élite
milan qui dit qui s'est tapé 325 fille
ces temps ci
en dix ans c'est beaucoup quand même à
mon avis la dernière femme qui
l'embrassé sur le vendre c'est sa mère
vous l'avez j -p alors vous vous gérez
le marais on vous voit dans un bar à
[ __ ] proposé trois mille francs une
fille qui se fait passer pour mannequin
et qui en fait est l'assistante du
journaliste
est de mèche avec le journaliste tout à
fait alors vous allez aussi on vous voir
au restaurant le cherche midi expliquant
qu'il est impossible de toucher enfin de
toucher aux filles parce que sinon la
presse vous tomberez dessus j'imagine
que quand vous dites ça vous avez un peu
peur devant les mêmes problèmes que le
patron de l' agence qui s'appelle jeunes
casablanca ce qu'elle fondateur d'élite
et qui a eu des problèmes avec une fille
qui s'appelait stephanie seymour et qui
à l'époque avait 16 ans il a eu des
problèmes avec la presse disons à
l'époque je crois qu'on n'en étaient
nombreux à craquer comme lui avec c'est
fini c'est mouais c'est fanny seymour
qui a épousé d'ailleurs un musicien elle
fait saison plutôt en allant vers 25
voix là et elle est avec maintenant je
crois que c'est tico torres 1 exactement
c'est pas un type de bonnes je vis
bon le même john casablanca d'ailleurs
en cinq ans maintenant 54 ans avec 1 à
56 7 avec une brésilienne puis d'avoir
22 ans il a déclaré marié deux enfants
marié deux enfants il a déclaré
casablanca un nouvel obs en 92 un modèle
qui est vierge est incapable de faire
passer un courant forces dans ces photos
c'est beau et votre grande concurrente
l' agence ford grande concurrence dans
le monde entier
cathy ford de l' agence ford ans les
filles de shefford c'est vrai qu'elles
ont pas droit de faire des pubs de
lingerie et des pubs de déodorant ah ben
c'est pas folichon cathy forte de l'
agence ford et vous me cachais jean
d'ormesson nom n'aurait pas ce qui
serait bien si vous mettiez physiquement
je préfère elle j'avais moi je vais voir
tous les deux cathy fort de l' agence
ford a dit en allant en parlant d'élite
en parlant d'élite assez bon je reste et
ça c'est vraiment pas le soir michel
c'est vraiment pas le soir on sait plus
comment aussi un jeu arte c'était pour
lui le seul fait de la galanterie
d'accord
quatorze agences or die la compétition
est normal mais je n'ai aucun respect
pour l élite ils ont pas d'éthique vous
savez dit elle au journaliste en
question il couche avec leur mannequin
occasionnel est vrai pacotille en agence
fort
alors le journal les filles donc gagner
votre confiance ce donal macintyre
gagner votre confiance vous lui dit
qu'il va la voir la finale à nice la
finale du elite lot de fans en délire et
vous dites qu à nice donc à la finale et
que après sur le bateau vous irez tout
sur le bateau et vous faites vous dit
pas mais vous faites un petit geste
comme ça qui signifie baiser des
glouglous dans la case
alors je termine après évidemment vous
me répondrez mais là j'explique pour nos
amis telle espèce menacée
dont vous avez démissionné
réintégrer vous avez démissionné en fait
que ça aujourd'hui vous êtes
démissionnaire non je me suis suspendu
volontairement chez un des plus gros
actionnaires d'élite donc ce que je veux
dire c'est
80 ça je te prends des positions de
recul pour mieux défendre mon histoire
bien alors maintenant j'ai fini ce que
je serais tenter de vous dire c'est que
dans la sphère c'est vous qui vous êtes
et baisers pour le fric et on m'a même
pas d'aimer 1er novembre
alors le reportage et des trucs et ben
si vous avez été le voir vous montrer ce
à n'importe quel professionnel de la
télévision du cinéma c'est a duré sept
mois un reportage pour neuf minutes de
programmes du croit il ya autour de moi
ni drogue aucun moment ni un mannequin à
aucun moment qu'elle soit en socket ou
que les à 90 ans il n'y a jamais une
femme réduite comme très très très déçu
en fait il ya ces noms à faire cette
histoire comprenez on a on a cherché à
rapporter encore de l'opprobre sur sur
ellipses que ces vendeurs dont c'est
très porteur et lita donc on s'est
retrouvé devant un événement pareil qui
était un truc très choquant et très très
moche pour la profession mais on est
tellement facilement attaquable les gens
sont beaux et gagnent bien leur vie ils
s'amusent ils sont très heureux entre
eux il ya toujours évidemment quelques
brebis qui s'égare dans la nature mais
ça se passe également dans les écoles on
peut pas tous surveillés et au delà de
ça on a voulu quand même on est rentré
quand même pleine tête dans cette
affaire on a réclamé les roches à la bbc
qui fait bien gardé nous les envoyer
puisqu'on démonter tout aussi à ce
moment là c'est pas trop compliqué et
c'est parti imaginez vous que ce type
parce qu'on a toujours les réponses mais
pas les questions à jean de reportages
mans on n'entend jamais leur porter
systématiquement pendant sept mois ce
type m'a demandé de l'emmener à des
dîners à des machins du truc dit rien il
avait très très n'entrait déçu le kit
n'a jamais rien vu rien compris mais on
a pris élite on avait ce projet un peu
plus en 2000 ans et des pillards de
milan ils ont trouvé ses profits qu'il
aura besoin d'arrondir ses fins de mois
chez marilyn qui n' a rien à voir dans
ce genre de trucs on avait ce truc bien
puis on a trouvé un joli papier cp
l'élite et puis un couillon du
raz-de-marée en effet de ne
on a livré sa à une presse qui a pas
beaucoup de d'éthique professionnelle en
france et qui est partie comme en 14
fédérale 3 contre avocat c'est une
harmonie votre avocat oui je crois qu'il
va attaquer les médias qui se sont fait
l'écho sans absolument sans donner
l'envié oui vous pouvez casser la vie
d'un type avec sartre d'une femme pire
c'est très simple on est devant un
promoteur de matin en prenant un t on
voir dépêche de l afp allons-y ces
jolies les mêmes cas sont des [ __ ] les
agences sont des macros on les drogue on
en abuse on est irrespectueux c'est un
métier très sain alors en revanche il ya
les patrons des deux syndicats de
mannequins qui s'appelle eric perceval
et servane scheer watts qui ont dit que
vous défendre par à eux disent que c'est
pas étonnant dumas vous savez le
syndicat des mannequins force ouvrière
avec neuf membres nous lisons neuf
membres syndicales et 20,15 force
ouvrière vous trouvez des mannequins
force ouvrière où ça commence bien et
perceval lui il s'est fait un petit
syndicat qui lui est très très personnel
il a un client c'est mon concurrent mais
le vrai syndicat des mannequins lui des
agences de mannequins n'a jamais été
interrogé on n'a d'ailleurs pas
interroger un mannequin ou de nice
uccelli tout d'ailleurs où il ya du
plaisir gerald marie le parisien le 3
décembre 99 qui interviewait un
mannequin qui s'appelle florence vous
l'avez lu j'imagine et qui dit non on
n'est pas chez madame claude le système
est plus pernicieux donc plus dangereux
et elle parle de dîners organisés par
les agences où il ya des des vieux
monsieur riches qui sont d'ailleurs
souvent beau gosse dit-elle qui viennent
alors moi je sais pas trop hein il ya
des mannequins qui sont ici linda était
mannequin d'ailleurs trop longtemps
puisque l'une où elle était mannequin
jusqu'à l'une d'entre vous a été amené à
un monde n'est aussi on me disait d'un
seul coup je regrette que ce soit ce
soit fou cette histoire en finale gt gt
maintenance et oui pendant pendant trois
ans catherine da et on m'a jamais
proposé d'aller dans l'eau si vous avez
des fois un booker qui une fois dans
l'année vous appelle dit voilà il ya une
soirée à tel endroit est ce que tu as
envie de venir ouais on dit oui
évidemment que ces connexions on y va
fort on a quand même du boulot le
lendemain moi j'ai toujours bien
je suis obligé je pose des questions
pour expliquer vous avez été mannequin
c'est vous on vous a jamais forcer non
c'est vrai que parfois mais je pense que
c'est comme tout c'est ce que vous
disiez c'est à dire qu'il ya je vois pas
pourquoi les agences de mannequins
serait particulièrement plus morale que
n'importe quel mot lieu à paris que ce
soit les écoles les courses
mais on aime on est bien plus surveillée
les ans une fille qui n'a pas 16 ans ne
travaille pas c'est le seul pays où les
mannequins sont salariés n'ont pas à
payer sur honoraires jean d'ormesson
nommez-moi fumée était mannequin
mais autour de moi on couchait aussi
vous qu'avec ou sans cage imagine dans
votre vie vous avez mais moi je l' ai vu
la cassette oui et effectivement je dois
dire que quand on la regarde c'est à
vomir un mais mais les procédés
qu'emploie le type qui fait le film sont
aussi écoeurant que ce qui décrit donc
je sais pas très crédible c'est trop
manipuler
vous je vous pose pas la question parce
que dans le football
on prend des pétards mais bon vous savez
quand on quand on connaît pas un milieu
et qu'on le voit de l'extérieur ont
toujours tenté de décrire certaines
choses mais bon ce qui se passe ce qui
se passe là ce bon ça peut se comparer
au foot aussi ont recherché des gosses
on les attire avec telle ou telle chose
un beau contrat dans un club dans un
club on y fait signer un papier mais bon
j'en arrive il faut pas non plus que à
cause de conversations de couloir et
d'une cassette que les gens n'ont pas vu
il faut pas non plus jeter le discrédit
sur toute une profession
c'est pas juste qu'il ya aussi des gens
qui sont très très bien alors
qu'on peut dire quand même pour poids
c'est vrai que les filles sont de plus
en plus jeunes et ça c'est la demande
assez le marché quoi il ya un problème
la
bbc c'est dans quel pays en angleterre
angleterre le plus gros fournisseur de
filles qui n'ont pas l'âge de travailler
dont qui ont 12 ans aux 13 ans et
l'angleterre moi j'ai trouvé que avec
sur cette cassette ya rien son
angleterre excusez moi je ressens un
petit peu car il est quand même ça c'est
à cause de la vache folle à mon avis
nous aurons quelque chose quelque part
mais là ce sont des producteurs de
jeunes filles soulage anormal d'être
mise dans une situation elles peuvent et
veulent et travail et mannequin autres
et il envoie ça en italie aux états-unis
à droite et à gauche c'est une
fourniture directe de là à déporter le
problème de la mise au travail de gosse
ou d'adolescentes qui n'ont pas 16 ans
et venir coucher ça à paris ouais et
appeler ça une espèce de protester
prostitution des enfants j'ai trouvé un
peu grosse aussi celle ci a il ya quand
même pas mal de règlement pour la saison
ce petit document et ayah paul et pierre
aussi les filles de l'est aussi c'est
vrai que ça favorise pas à sears et des
filles qui sont complètement déboussolés
qui arrive de tchécoslovaquie des défis
dans des défis de l'ess coéducation
remarquable et les filles de l'est très
très très bien et vous savez il ya des
plus de partout aussi un alors
mesdemoiselles vous vous êtes chez
l'élite depuis plus de 300 ans
maintenant mais vous mais moi
ici pour dire que gérard lemarié vous
vous obliger à faire des dîners avec des
monsieurs j'imagine
tous les beaux gosses anglais ça jamais
presse à
bombay très bien donc l'émission est
terminée donc merci d'être venus a fait
les corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux